okay hey folks welcome back to the Dark
Horse podcast live stream with animals
here and there we are ready to address
some questions from our temporary
temporary Studio James Madison uh the uh
incorrectly gendered Labrador given her
name uh has decided to contribute to the
questions for this q a so uh for those
of you I think it is relatively few of
you who would just be listening to the Q
a rather than watching you will see that
she has got her nose uh firmly ensconced
at my computer and she is making
editorial comments as we speak so after
the degree that I read questions that
don't actually exist I'm going to blame
Maddie blame Maddie yeah all right well
she's not going to complain no no she
won't she's she's a sweetheart all right
we're going to start with uh the
question that was voted on
um in the Discord this week which is
this for you Brett
you mentioned in the Bridget Fantasy
episode that you would talk about the
one child policy in China but never got
back to it can you talk about that wow
did I not get back to it they're not
going I think I did not get back to it
now that you mentioned it well I didn't
mention it yeah all right I'll finish
that out sure
um here's the the long and short of it
R.A Fisher the great evolutionary
biologist and not so great anti-semite
um and great father of modern statistics
father of modern statistics
um I mean no he was actually a terrific
anti-semite
I think we need to Define our terms here
I mean I think
being an anti-semite he was really good
he excelled at it
um I'm hoping that's not true but anyway
uh anyway he was a brilliant
evolutionary biologist he was important
in both Evolution and biology and
statistics and had a lot to say about
sex ratios yes so here's the question
given that a
let's make this humans uh a human female
is limited in the number of offsprings
she can produce in a lifetime the
maximum number being something jaw
dropping in the 60s a particular woman
who chronically gave birth to twins and
basically was able to hand them off to
be wet nursed and raised by others but
anyway
even that extraordinary run is very
limited compared to what a man with
unlimited access to uh fertile females
could produce and with rather a small
fraction of the effort I would say
rather a small fraction of the effort
yeah yeah
um in any case it seems that it would be
vastly better evolutionarily to be male
than female which raises the question
why females and males are roughly
equivalent sex ratio at Birth
the answer to that question is that the
variance is much higher for males but
the
um the average
utility is the same however that changes
when there is a deficit of males or
females in other words if you were a
female choosing what sex Offspring to
produce if you were producing Offspring
into a world in which males had been
depleted than producing males would be a
great idea if you were producing
Offspring into a world in which females
have been depleted then you would want
to produce females in a world in which
you know nothing about the potential for
mates it would be basically a coin flip
so anyway given all of that hence the
one-to-one sex ratio at maturity that we
see across
um sexually reproducing species in all
domains yeah now there's a lot more to
be said there some other hypotheses
places where individuals might gamble
One Direction or another but all else
being equal
uh you would expect the one-to-one sex
ratio the one child policy in China
distorts the one-to-one sex ratio
through selective abortion which results
in a bias just I mean you said it but
just to make it explicit
a one-child policy does not inherently
distort a sex ratio a one-child policy
in combination with a cultural
preference for male children will
distort the sex ratio right so what you
have is a distorted sex ratio and the
question is why does The evolutionary
logic that fisher outline not apply in
other words
were I Chinese which I'm not but why
Chinese and we're I in some position to
choose what sex Offspring I wanted to
produce in a world where there are
excess males it would be a slam dunk to
produce females a female would be able
to marry up as it were because males
would be competing for a small number of
females so the sex Ratio or sex ratio
should equalize and it doesn't why
the answer to that puzzle I suspect
is that there are circumstances in which
a bias makes sense and those
circumstances involve for example let's
say you were up against carrying
capacity that is to say your land mass
held about as many people as it was
going to hold
and you were preparing for war
right the idea is a excess of males
especially sexually frustrated males
without reproductive prospects at home
is basically an army minus weapons
and so the question something I wrote
about
um
or in the first or second year we were
teaching at Evergreen
is the question of is there an
evolutionary program that prepares for
uh War by biasing in favor of males and
should we be concerned that China is
effectively one way or the other
producing that
pressure and selection is failing to
equalize it therefore
in other words were we looking at the
run-up to War I don't know the answer
that question but I do know that the
bias in favor of males is an
evolutionary Oddity not easy to explain
by standard evolutionary Dynamics
because to the extent that you have a
bias in favor of one sex or the other
you should produce the rare sex that's
the logic
unfortunately I made the mistake again
of hitting Refresh on the questions just
as you were finishing and now it's
spinning that's more like defresh yeah
I'm trying but uh all right we are
trying taking some time yeah
all right
um and it's unlocked so I'm just going
to log back in here just uh just give me
a minute here we go
here it is okay
um
uh this first one which I don't know why
it's at the top given the way I've got
things weighted uh but I'll ask it
because I have no idea even what this oh
wait it just disappeared
I apparently don't have any idea what
I'm doing uh
I don't know who this is curious your
thoughts on the Kyrie Irving situation
if you have been following it
you know does that mean anything to you
my guess is if I knew the situation I
could reverse engineer who that is but I
don't know yeah you need you need you
need to leave room for the cats all
right because who's paying the rent
around here you that is an interesting
question not any of these animals
actually but uh still uh
that's great we were cold during the
break but uh we're not we're not feeling
cold anymore we're just feeling lots of
carnivorous love at the moment
God
all sorts of love going on all right
um
I have not yet read this question I just
came in and it's long so I'm going to
read it I don't know what's coming I
think BP here stands for Bridget
fennessy after listening to the Bridget
fantasy interview I discussed with my
gen Z Son I discussed it with my gen Z
son he thinks that the biggest
contributors to the less sex situation
are both performance anxiety akin to
being anxious about being boring on a
date and interestingly he feels they
have rediscovered the seriousness of sex
and want to engage only with people they
care about this son is in no way
conservative I found the conversation
fascinating and rewarding thanks Brett
for the conversation starter
that's super cool that is interesting if
uh if if this young man is reporting
accurately
what's not in there is why performance
anxiety would be anything other than
normal is it because of the seriousness
that they've rediscovered is that the
idea I thought what was coming when I
saw performance anxiety was um based on
what is being seen in porn
and in you know not quite porn but porn
adjacent porn influence things with sex
and sexual activity all over the place
visible all the time such that you might
imagine that as you were
entering that scene not knowing anything
as inherently you wouldn't as a beginner
it feels like everyone else knows
everything about what to do at all times
and of course that's not true for anyone
yep not true and you really don't want
to be those people anyway
the people who know everything about
every possible no official situation I
mean the things depicted
that's that's not the sex life you want
to build yeah so
yeah but so I mean yeah very interesting
um
yeah so two things I guess let me just
read it again
I often can't quite take in the context
if I'm reading aloud I have to read it
to myself to see what what is being said
that the biggest contributors to the
less sex situation are performance
anxiety performance anxiety and
rediscovering the seriousness of sex and
wanting to engage only with people they
care about I I hope I hope that's true
at a general level I wonder I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna put our producer on
the spot
um I don't see that Trend yeah right
um I mean I feel like our our 18 year
old son slash producer of Dark Horse
um has now a small group of people who
you feel like or you know being serious
about such things
um but overall it's hard to find it's
very hard to find no I have not seen
that Trend at all yeah or the second
name specifically about yeah
rediscovering the seriousness of sex I
don't see that at all in yeah almost
anyone that I talked to
um I want to at the risk of making
this question potentially awkward for
the people involved in asking it one
thing that's not even a question really
just a comment so this is this is no
we're not treating this as a
conversation starter yes yes we are okay
well we're going to continue the
conversation one thing that
um
I have heard and read
is that young people are unable to
perform especially males because
effectively porn delivers very specific
content targeted at very specific niches
basically creating fetishes that these
things become necessary in order uh to
get excited and so that introduces a
problem which might read as performance
anxiety when really what it is is the
fetishization of sex yeah I guess that's
there's a little bit more mechanism
there that sort of I think that's what I
was trying to say but without any of the
specificity of what you just
okay
well uh cool and wow that's really
uncool
um
but yeah I mean there's it's who would
have thought there are a lot of things
about that we could say this about but
if I'd said to you back when we met each
other in
we met each other in 1985. yeah
when we were uh 16 yes
um if I had said to you then we were
good friends pretty quickly right uh
that we would at some point be talking
about how people our age weren't having
enough sex
people who were the age we were then
yeah are not having enough sex
um it would have seemed uh like in a
like dystopian stuff well and like
science fiction that is too stupid to
ever reach Market because No One's Gonna
believe it yeah right yeah so it is it
is in so many ways a very strange moment
that is quite true I must say that
having the dog's head on the laptop does
not make it as easy to use the laptop as
it might be but it's very Charming yeah
I know she's just I think she's she's
making a land grab and I think she's
winning there's a reason that laptops
don't come with Labradors yeah they're
not laptops they're laptops exactly
okay
well
okay
if team red takes the house and or
Senate I see impeachment as not far off
the horizon
Could That Be an Effective venue to
bring back governance curious uh
this is a second question within the
first cure also curious your thoughts on
Tulsi leaving the Democrats
um and then he also says I assume he
regarding your podcast style you managed
to pull off a healthy balance between
entertainment and education don't change
um cool thank you uh so two things here
um he's he's predicting that if
the house or the senate or both go red
that impeachment is going to be on the
table I don't know what the grounds for
impeachment would be I mean I don't well
I don't understand at all you don't need
grants anymore
and this is the Republicans fault
the that you don't need grounds yeah
yeah as much as I do because of clip
because of tested Bill Clinton yeah yeah
I was just talking about this with
someone yes yeah yeah the that
impeachment was a um it was a farce it
was a farce it made a farce of the
system yeah and so anyway the point is
impeachment has now been normalized yeah
um I think unless I dreamed it I think
Joe Biden yesterday said I'm hearing
that if the Republicans win I'm going to
be impeached what and he said I don't
even know what I would be impeached for
maybe I dreamed that but I believe I
didn't
in any case in any case yeah please look
that up
um I mean being mentally incompetent
unfortunately is not the grounds for
impeachment no but it is grounds for
removal yes but that's different from
impeachment yeah I agree and that was
exactly the point I was going to make is
that I do think that the man should be
removed from office because he's
incompetent and this is dangerous yeah
um yeah I'm not wrong well I don't
that's something an article yesterday
says Joe Biden acknowledges he faces
impeachment yep on what but in some way
you're I mean there's at least has to be
a cover story like oh yes well I mean
look it's not gonna be hard to find
stuff I mean he the fact is it a son's
connection to Ukraine and laptop and
that's not going to do it you're going
to need evidence of his connection
um but let's put it this way he has
participated in
um lots of stuff look I don't think he's
guilty because I don't think he's a
great politician who's been living in
Washington he's an influence Peddler
from way back the fact is I think at the
moment you know keeping him on script is
kind of his job and that the actual
policy stuff keeping him on script is uh
the job of everybody around him and his
job is
uh trying to stay trying to not gaff
go an entire day without a gaff
um
it's tough but anyway the point is uh
yeah I could see impeachment I could
also see but I forget being an effective
venue to bring back governance
nope
I think it's gonna be a circus well
let's put it this way I guess you know
there's always
there was a way to deal with Trump with
this mechanism that would have involved
mature people engaged in governance it
didn't happen there is a way for mature
people engaged in governance to deal
with Biden too and it effectively I
think would mean
um
emissaries of
both parties hopefully privately
approaching him and saying Mr President
um
this has to come to an end you're not in
a position to do this job that is a
danger to this country if you love this
country it's time for you to step down
we don't want to have to do
um we do not want to have to take action
far better for you to acknowledge where
we've arrived and gracefully blah blah
blah blah blah but if we have to we will
yeah right yep I could see that would
take some Patriots Yeah that would have
that conversation yep
um and you know as much as
I don't like Biden I don't like these uh
influence Peddlers one bit and he
strikes me as an influence Peddler if he
were to gracefully step out of the way
that would at least be an honorable Mark
at the end of his record and yes
um I think it's the way it should go it
does leave us with Kamala Harris who
then should also step down for just
being awful
[Laughter]
um but you know so be it yeah
um and uh Curious your thoughts on Tulsi
leaving the Democrats
um yeah I mean she had to she was going
to it's bedtime congratulations Kudos
all that yeah I mean look
the
party
doesn't exist something has donned it as
a cloak and is now moving through
history using it as a weapon but the
Democratic party doesn't exist any
reasonable person uh you know why am I
still a member of the democratic party
because in theory my vote are you I
think I think I am still registered as a
Democrat yeah I I with the move I um I'm
now you know let's put it this way the
only reason I think that's not a slam
dunk is because but in Washington
actually it doesn't in uh you can vote
oh that's true yeah it's you've got I
remember the language it's not like open
primaries here Oregon doesn't have open
primaries but Washington does yeah all
right well I will seriously rethink it
because there's no there's no allegiance
to I have no allegiance to the color
blue and other than that there's nothing
about this party that resembles anything
I ever signed up for
yeah yeah
all right next question now we're going
to do a brief q a this week because we
spent a long time on the uh on the main
episode why do copper and silver have
healing properties
think colloidal silver
SSD parentheses Silvadene magnets I
don't know what magnets are doing here
exactly Copper Fit Etc
so I don't know
the only one of those that I've ever
heard in the context of health is
colloidal silver and I don't know
and I and I haven't perceived it I
pursued it I know that it has this sort
of machine of of crazy woo-woo and I
think it's actually there's some there's
some reality there but I don't know I
don't know exactly what it is yeah I
mean
uh
chemistry
is the study of electron interactions
metals are grouped together because of
similar electromagnetic properties
that is to say their electron shells
unite them
what those electron shells do is it that
free electrons are readily uh collected
by Metals I don't know
but I will just argue it's not
it is not implausible that I mean you
know a copper
uh Bowl
has an effect on the whipping of eggs
right egg whites egg whites yeah right
that is an electromagnetic influence
that it exerts on egg whites and so
really the question is does it make
sense that copper pans cook also I can't
remember what like the egg whites in
Copper Bowl as long as you it's pure you
can't get anybody yolk in it and it
doesn't work right but copper pans also
cook some things a little bit
differently than say cast iron or enamel
cast iron yep and you know a lot of
metals have interesting properties I
learned from my grandfather that the
reason that aluminum doesn't rust is
that aluminum corrodes so quickly and so
uniformly that effectively gains a
protective layer
um it like it's not self-anodizing but
if it effectively is protected from
contact with oxygen by the immediate
um
corrosion of the surface the um what
I mean that would suggest a constant
erosion a constant shrinking no no no no
no no what it suggests is that the
mechanism creates a seal that stops the
process it's a self-arresting process
nothing is made in the factory and the
aluminum itself you can you can machine
aluminum so that it is suddenly exposed
and that exposed aluminum then picks up
a corroded layer that's so thin that it
doesn't strike you as corroded and it
blocks further corrosion now I hope my
grandfather was right
um although I think he has escaped
responsibility at this point on account
of not being alive I'm not being alive
anymore yeah no that does help yeah
um
I'm very curious about this and neither
of us prepped or anything at all except
that I was literally just
um buying another
um
baking sheet yeah another baking sheet
and a cookie sheet yesterday and what we
have are you know we did we never buy
stuff with these non-stick Coatings
they're
carcinogenic they're terrible just you
know don't don't cook with that crap
um but I was looking for one of these
half sheet pans
um of which we um we have
stainless and then we've got these
Pebble sheet cooking cookie sheets which
are so good they've got this like this
little rugosity in the surface what it
is is they dripped metal onto it and
then they machined it flat that's fine
it's irrelevant to the question at the
moment it's cool
and these Pebble sheets which only come
in 100 aluminum
and the uh the half sheet pans come in a
number of different uh
materials and non-stick is the one that
most people are buying and then they're
stainless and then there's
um basically stainless coated with
aluminum
and the argument that the manufacturers
of the pure stainless ones make is don't
buy
aluminum on top of stainless because as
soon as you chip it then you can't use
it anymore
like why wouldn't you be able to use it
anymore and I'm wondering if how this
would interface with the like aluminum
self heals in some way
well what they're saying is if you chip
through the aluminum exposing the
stainless steel that you can't use it
anymore and what my question is is given
that we cook with stainless why is it
why is this stainless not right
acceptable don't know
um
I will say there are other examples that
are sort of reminiscent of the
explanation on aluminum that Harry gave
me
for example when you weld titanium
you do so inside of a physical cup
structure the welding tip exists inside
of a cup structure which you flood with
argon is this did you when you learned
to weld I never did this you didn't do
this nope
um this is one of the reasons that
titanium is so hard to weld is that you
have to manage this argon flow and the
idea is the Argon excludes oxygen and if
there was oxygen present in the weld as
you made it it would be uh fragile so
there'd be little bubbles right
there are several different Metals in
which it's true
um but the point is the idea that
there's some very rapid chemical
reaction in exposure to oxygen that
affects certain Metals enough that you
can't even get a weld done yeah yeah
okay is the same same sort of deal it
sounds implausible because we're all
familiar with what seems like the speed
of rust right which is actually also not
what is actually going on our perception
of the speed of rust is like wait a
minute uh I left you know I left that
out and now you know a little while
later it's Rusty but but actually we see
this with just you know most many of the
um Skillets that we cook with are cast
iron
and excuse me if you don't dry the
bottom so the inside should be well
seasoned so that it really doesn't have
any water that sits on it so this is not
should not be an issue on the on the
cooking surface but the bottom that's
going to be on the stove top you have to
dry completely right away if you let it
just dry on a rack it's going to be
rusty by the time you get back that's
enough it's not enough rest that you
can't like rub it off but yeah but it's
it's going to rust very quickly actually
yeah it does dress but anyway I think
the point is metals are not all of them
but many of them are and maybe it's all
of them and we just can't see as is the
case with aluminum
highly reactive and so it wouldn't be
surprising if that same property had an
interaction if you had an imbalance that
was at the electron level in some tissue
that the application of a metal might
not
um soak up free electrons somehow
neutralizing the thing that was causing
whatever disease so that is a very
blunt imprecise yeah and it predicts
that if copper and silver have healing
properties then so too should the other
whatever whatever that class of metals
is I don't remember there's like metals
and there's like alkali metals like
whatever other metals are like copper
and silver chemically should also have
healing properties if if it's a yes
chemical and you've got to balance
healing with toxic properties you know
indeed so yeah it ain't like there
aren't Metals with very serious yes
don't don't try this at home with
Mercury yeah our web
um
yeah
uh
the brain doesn't fully develop until
age 25 is being used to imply that
intelligent forward-looking adult
thinking is not on online before that
age is this true or misleading I think
it has been misunderstood and my hope is
that adult thinking doesn't start until
2025 and then it's going to kick in and
suddenly we're going to start behaving
properly in a reasonable way we will
rescue this beautiful planet
I'm hoping yeah yeah
we could yeah we could tread water that
long yeah
yeah I will I will say two things one I
do think that there is something quite
true about the idea that neurological
development is unusual in humans
terminates later than we think but it's
also true there's probably a sex
difference
probably um since girls
um girls have earlier onset
um development of you know physical and
psychological and mental stuff
um and you know the word that we tend to
use for this that has the positive
connotation is precocious they tend to
have more precocial development but what
that means also is that
um boys are more likely to continue
getting you know more awesome for longer
into adulthood
yep I I think that's probably right and
it is also true that an awful lot of the
stuff that matters is the level of
dendritic connections rather than gross
anatomy and so that process doesn't
terminate right it may slow down it may
have patterns but the fact is as you are
thinking and remembering and learning
and all of these processes that we know
continue
um you are making dendritic connections
strengthening dendritic connections and
so in some sense the right model is none
of this stuff ever ends it may get
harder but the idea that there's a a
Terminus is probably just wrong yeah and
I mean maybe maybe oh God maybe the most
obvious answer what just happened
um is the phrasing as described here
the brain doesn't fully develop until
age 25 and yes I've heard that I think
we've all heard that uh is explicitly
binary and it assumes it it reveals a
very naive misunderstanding of what
humans are really one that is so naive
that all of us should be able to see
through it there is no
before moment X you know I am like this
and after moment X I'm I'm like that
um
even even puberty which is as close as
humans get to a metamorphic process is
graded is
do go on
I was just thinking that the process in
which uh one stubs their toe is pretty
close to biting well as I was saying
it's like actually there's lots of stuff
that if there is a before and after
right like you know
fertilization is a before and after
birth is a before and after orgasm is a
before and after like there's a lot of
your bone break like there's a lot of
actually like discreet moments in time
of things you can do or experience with
your body that there's a before and
after but
when you're talking about the brain is
it done yeah done like what what is that
that doesn't that doesn't make any sense
given what the brain is and what humans
are and what we're doing on the planet
so
um I mean I think maybe your point about
dendritic Connections is the the most
obviously relevant one I think there's
going to be a lot of other things too
and with regret you know and maybe also
you made the point of like dendritic
connections over gross anatomy I think
the the thing that's hiding there
for those who don't haven't necessarily
thought about what it might mean for the
brain doesn't fully develop is I think
that if you go one level deeper on those
claims and you can't go very deep
because they don't make sense very deep
if you go one level deeper you'll find
people saying wow you know the frontal
lobe uh you know is still you know
growing relative to the rest of the size
of the rest of the brain I think that's
a claim right I think it's like
different ratios of lobes uh in the
cerebral cortices relative to one
another it's like okay that may be true
but that doesn't suggest that there's a
moment at which and now you're ready
that said we have to pick some moments
in time you know as you know the
founders of the country said
what is it to to run for Congress is it
25
for president is 35 and I think for
congress it's either 25 I want to say 25
28 30 something nods can't be 30.
um I don't think I think 25 is right I
think yeah
um and you know
this is a Zack points out that running a
car is 25 yeah
um so you know we pick we picked these
moments right uh 18 to vote and go to
war and 21 to drink in many places 18 to
drink in many places
um but that's more about us needing to
have a demarcation that we can then base
laws on rather than
um imagining that there is
real
palpable truth to that as a line a
categorical line for people
yep
to the extent that my computer is often
giving me trouble these days right now
it's primarily about the fact that
there's a dog lying on it I'm just gonna
say yep um
the issues I'm having are mostly about
about canine and origin yes canine
origin
please be the white pill to my black
pill
for the past seven years holding on to
Liberal ideals fairness and peaceful
discourse has lost us every battle is
liberalism a brainworm destined to just
keep us out of the way
oh this should be pretty easy okay it's
really a very simple distinction between
liberalism as adherence to a
value structure and a belief system
versus liberalism as a club
and I don't mean club like a bludgeon I
mean club like a gathering of people I
didn't need to clarify but I did need to
clarify because it's 2022.
um
the so the point is liberalism has done
great it's done really really well it's
so good that the conservatives are now
really concerned about the loss of
liberalism and they are defending it
yeah this guy Chad who says please be
the white pill to my black pill
specifies the past seven years he as
someone who apparently
still is holding on to these ideals
liberalism as he had been throughout his
entire life I have no idea how old he is
would agree that liberalism largely won
that many of the things liberals were
fighting for in the 50s 60s 70s 80s 90s
even
have been accepted and that's a win yeah
but he's saying the past seven years and
I'm not sure you know since 2015 I know
I don't know exactly I don't I don't
know when this all starts but uh
that it's it's causing us to lose
so that's it's I don't I don't think
that I don't pointing out that
liberalism many of the things that
liberalism was fighting for with regard
to you know civil rights and
um equal rights for women and all of
this have been accepted
isn't it isn't responsive to this
question but I I think it is I think
it's not there's nothing about the
liberalism that has been invalidated or
that sticking to it is causing us to
lose
we are watching it unhooked we are
watching it unhooked by its inverse by
illiberal nonsense racism is back right
with a Vengeance it's not white
nationalism that's back it's racism that
is motivated by people who claim the
mantle of liberalism but are a liberal
right likewise
the uh equality of women is now in
Jeopardy the protection of children is
now in Jeopardy all of these things are
illiberal so I think and actually
foreign
people are now coalescing lots of
heterodox Liberals are coalescing around
the defense of these things it's not
just conservatives defending that we are
seeing liberalism reborn
um I didn't even want to say From the
Ashes of this monstrous woke Revolution
but as a rebellion because lots of us
aren't conservatives and yet we adhere
to these things and
anyway look at the very least
um
give it a couple weeks weeks oh yeah we
don't know where we are we got two in in
an era in which almost nothing hopeful
happens we've got one very hopeful thing
on the horizon we've got the potential
for a truly
freedom-oriented Twitter to be
stabilized and for us to be able to find
out what discussion is supposed to sound
like rather than be managed by
authoritarians from above and we've got
a wild card with the election so
um it is not the moment for despair it
is the moment for popcorn
I mean you want some popcorn so you can
see what happens and then two weeks from
now we can talk about whether or not the
world has gone back to its insane
equilibrium or whether it is headed to
some new equilibrium that arguably might
even not be insane
so here's something I learned this week
that is may not seem apropos and I
probably should have brought it up in
the main in the main live stream but uh
so the Brazilian election happened and
bolsonaro lost to Lula and Lula had been
the president and was removed in sort of
a fog of corruption and accusations and
such and bolsonaro who's a kind of a
trumpian figure uh and you know
certainly stood for things like
raise the Amazon who needs it anyway
let's erect Burger Kings instead
um but also jump in and that he stood up
to some stupid and um
and is not
um you know is is is largely sort of a
force unto himself but who you know it
was seems to be seemed to be capable of
doing some good
Lula uh Progressive bolsonaro I don't
even know what he would call himself
um
both of whom with absolutely dedicated
ideological
proponents
uh met in this election the pre the
second round and uh Lula one and there
were immediately protests in the streets
and enough so that actually people can't
fly back into Brazil now so like you
know person we know
um a relative was visiting them and was
due to fly back to Sao Paulo in a couple
of weeks actually and the airline was
like yeah you're not gonna be able to
get back for a while like the the
streets are blocked we're not like no
one's coming back in for a while so
that's amazing and what I asked the the
acquaintance of ours was like and what
would have happened if Lula had lost and
she said
same thing
so in Brazil doesn't matter the
ideologues on both sides wreak havoc
because neither of them will accept the
election results either way and it
doesn't and you know you know she has
her preferences and I don't need to
share them here uh but you know her
Point her point was be you someone who
thinks that Lua Lua you know Lula has
the capacity to actually bring Brazil
back into uh a country that is
forward-looking and doing good in the
world or if you think that bolsonaro is
the right guy for that there will be
people who will disrupt the Democratic
process after an election no matter who
wins
yeah I take a slightly different View
it is interesting well this is I mean
this is a Brazilian person I understand
that my view is
we are all a bit myopic
around
our developmental environment is one in
which nations played a particular role
the fact that
Brazil in some ways looks like a
variation on our own political theme
right a tension an irresolvable tension
between two factions that want to pull
in opposite directions in which each
election is contested and uh yada yada
I think something there's a generating
function that is producing that
phenomenon
and it has to do a bit with modernity
and a bit with our you know hyper novel
political environment it may have to do
with some force that is Supernatural I
don't mean Supernatural but
supernational is really what I mean
um yep a supernational force that is
powerful enough that basically it sees
its interests here and there and it
creates the same kind of political
environment in which it can make I mean
basically a fiercely divided nation
in which it power is traded back between
two mutually exclusive perspectives is
one in which it makes no progress in any
useful Direction yeah and therefore
something else which which to make
progress uh of its own in spite of that
Nation might have an advantage
so I don't know what's going on but it's
interesting that that pattern what you
have described looks like the U.S why
why at this moment should both countries
look alike
exactly like the U.S
um not exactly but because I don't like
the the take from our Brazilian friend
was actually even the kinds of protests
and the extremity of them
um looks the same no matter which
extreme side wins
and you can
tell apart
the ways that uh pseudo left wing and
maybe I should even be calling it suit
or right wing
protesters at both of the extremes will
protest in the U.S when an election goes
away they didn't uh
yep no ours looks different yeah
um so I mean I it just it raises
they raises questions about
um they're getting you know the organic
nature of the protests and uh how you
know what what what exactly is disagreed
about like is it some of the same people
even I'm just like oh well it's time to
Pro I what I was really looking forward
to was protest so I'm going to put on a
different outfit and yeah that is that
is obviously what antifa feels like to
some degree well I mean I don't I would
be very surprised unless there's some
orchestrated thing if the same people
would be protesting either way
but I do think there are certain ways
that you know from afar well but antifa
managed to protest uh
you know after the the presidential
election last time because even Biden
isn't going far enough in the direction
that they wanted yeah even though we had
a choice between two and they definitely
didn't want the guy who lost and but
they did still decided to go out and
burn [ __ ] down yeah afterwards because
um because they wanted to burn [ __ ] down
that's true right yep so yeah anyway
um there's there's there are a number of
important things here that I can't quite
get a handle on
all right couple more questions before
we stop for the day
can we find the Elon Musk of YouTube or
at least a coalition of Liberty loving
people to buy them out and Protect free
speech you know who I thought might be
the Elon Musk of YouTube
Elon Musk
well
let's put it this way I do not I do not
think it will have escaped his notice
that
much as
Twitter is unique among Platforms in
terms of the it's not by far not the
biggest
but the leverage that it has over
thought is potentially very great
um the
role that YouTube plays with respect to
reaching the public
is so large that it will not have
escaped his notice that it plays its
level of importance May rival Twitter
but in a different way and so I don't
know what he's got planned he certainly
talked about presumably YouTube's valued
at a hell of a lot more than Twitter now
oh yeah
um like it's just a different it's got a
thing it's got to be at least an an
order of magnitude yeah different I I
would agree that it is sure to be valued
more I'm not saying he can make the same
play right but the question is well is
you know
the thing about zero is a special number
is
if there was a YouTube
that just simply did what YouTube does
and didn't oppress those who wished to
explore the truth
we'd all go we'd all sign up and the
problem is that what exists
rumble's making that move it's making
that move but it's ghettoized right
and it's you know I'm I'm rude
odyssey's trying which is you know we're
putting our stuff on Odyssey rumble's
trying
I'm rooting for these things but there's
a difference between a player at a
symmetrical level stepping in and trying
to build something that successfully
competes yep
um and so anyway
yes somebody needs to do this for
YouTube but the landscape we live in if
Twitter gets stabilized as a free speech
platform
it's a totally different landscape what
happens to you too I mean look at what
happened to Facebook's value in light of
Twitter's change
I don't know plunged Facebook yeah even
though they're unlike commodities
huh
well I didn't know that let me ask you
if you had a gigantic platform with
really high production values but it was
propaganda
and then some free speech thing
that is somewhere in the neighborhood of
as important Rises up and your
propaganda is going to look absurd
changes the value yeah maybe they should
have
was the the
political version you said like govern
rather than doing whatever they were
doing maybe they should have actually
being been engaged in some kind of like
media as opposed to erecting PolitiFact
and other pseudo fact-checking
organizations yeah and well and there's
a question also of how free they are
what Faustian Bargains have they made
with whom on the basis that uh you know
the people who uh are engaged in wrong
think are really some kind of terrorism
right you know we don't know what these
entities are we don't know you know the
fascism has United the corporate with
the governance and so that's that's the
way isn't it it is the way yes um so I
don't know I I don't know what Facebook
is
that's great now I'm gonna have
nightmares yeah sorry about that yeah
okay
um
two oh okay I said one more question
after this let's just do three really
quickly here
um one of which I'm gonna say right away
that I don't have an answer but invite
um people to who might know something to
put them in the comments here and I'll
see if we can um Source anything
I have been dealing with benzo
withdrawal symptoms and I'm looking for
answers any research on benzo's effects
on Gaba receptors you can point to or
researchers names that might come to
mind love your podcast thank you both so
I don't know this research space at all
uh I think I just ran across something
that struck me as important but I can't
remember what it was
um
I know who I'm gonna ask
okay
um I don't know I guess we can revisit
it yeah
um okay revisit I'm gonna forward this
question to the next session and it'll
show up again hey look at that that is
thank you Kyle who designed this for us
thank you for making that an option
which I almost never use
um two quick questions before we go
any thoughts on I don't even know how to
pronounce it the the man formerly known
as Kanye West how do you pronounce is it
yay
I'm like
I mean presumably Prince still showed up
places after he renamed himself some
crazy looking series of symbols
the on Cuisine I thought he was several
things no wasn't he an ankh oh I don't
even know
okay
yay we decided that's how he pronounces
his name though I'm guessing any any
thoughts on yay's statements about
Jewish media
well they did strike me as a dad but
Anthony
um
you know I mean look I I let's put it
this way this is a this is a difficult
question anti-Semitism is
an evergreen problem it reasserts itself
and it can obviously end in disaster I
believe
I know exactly
why this happens and it has to do with
the fact that Jews are a very tiny
population that lives as a diaspora
which makes us vulnerable and so at the
point you get to what in our book we
describe as transfer Frontiers when the
technological Frontiers have uh petered
out and are not on the horizon there are
no more Geographic Frontiers theft is
the way and so a small population of
people that live interspersed with other
people is a go-to target living in
diaspora any population is inherently
not in a Homeland a historic Homeland
yeah I mean by definition that's what
diaspora is right now
you would think that a black American
would
understand would experience something
similar and recognize that Jews aren't
his enemy even if they're individual
Jews at least an African-American an
African who has come to live in America
which maybe should also be called an
African-American but like some someone
whose ancestors were brought against
their will yep
um uh might understand this in the same
way even though Jews weren't obviously
brought to the US against right it's a
very different origin story and that
origin story has everything to do in my
opinion with the difference in how these
populations have done in other words if
you're hobbled as a slave population in
order to keep you docile and then you're
freed that does not give you the tools
necessary to to compete well just as
many many African immigrants African
immigrants by choice to the U.S have
done extraordinarily well yeah on
average do much better right yeah I
don't think any of this has anything to
do with endogenous characteristics but
the point is you know blacks in the U.S
are always at a disadvantage because
it's a minority already that has
difficulty protecting itself
Jews are in a different spot but it's a
variation on a theme and anyway it's a
Pity that uh that Kanye
sees fit to hold forth are you dead
naming him now or I don't know
I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily not do
it but uh but yeah somehow it's only
dead naming if you've also decided that
you're living in a fantasy world in
which you are the sex that you're not
yeah if you've just changed your name no
that's not dead naming yeah in any case
let's just
sum total here
yep what he said is
pretty offensive am I weirded out that
some guy said offensive [ __ ] about Jews
not really
um I sort of think you know we have to
be very careful about
anti-Semitism gelling into a movement
that wants to take action but by and
large we've become way too sensitive
about
um you know the way people from
different populations
talk about each other get used to each
other right we've become so sensitive
that these things we we pretend that
people don't have ideas about other
people
um and then we're shocked when somebody
says something beyond the pale and the
point is
I think he said some really unfortunate
things I wasn't terribly troubled but a
guy said some really unfortunate things
that
is a thing that happens and the real the
real problem is that at the moment there
seems to be an audience for
anti-Semitism and this again goes back
to the idea that when people are feeling
resource stressed they start looking for
vulnerable populations they can demonize
and steal from and you know that's why
the Jews end up on the wrong end of this
is uh that history keeps delivering that
um that sequence of events and it's time
we recognize what it is this is this is
why I have the argument with Dawkins
that I have which is you can't afford
not to have this conversation it will
keep happening
right if you don't talk about the
lineage aspect of this it will keep
happening the only way out is for us to
say here's the predisposition here's the
sequence of events and here's the
conditions necessary in order for that
thing not to trigger right that's what
we have to do and not talking about it
won't get us there
that's right
um I have forwarded the last question
that I want to talk about
um to next week it's about uh Pinker and
blank slatism
the parents being fungible so we're
going to love the idea of forwarding
things to next week
yes but well actually I will actually
see them yep and we will we will get
them but that we're just
uh
we have run out of time so
um we will be back next week same time
different place
uh what will become the same place after
next week going forward until it is no
longer the same place the temporary
permanent Studio yes will hopefully be
up and running it will be
as our producer uh May uh find new
parents and a new uh podcast to produce
if if it doesn't happen by next would it
be fair to sum up the situation as we
have we have forwarded the temporary
permanent Studio to next week not really
I was going to say yes but I'm going to
go with Zach on this one because I think
I think we should leave him in charge of
of making making all this happen well
then I will say we have reached the
point in the podcast where we are
ganging up on me and therefore it's
probably the time to make a graceful
exit and forward ourselves to next week
how are we getting up on you oh I don't
know
you were going to agree with me but then
he disagreed and you decided to join him
he was like how do you know I was going
to agree with you because you said
something yeah did I yes I see there's
video okay
but I don't I don't think that that
means that either of us were gang up on
you I just think that he made a point
that I agreed with more yeah
I was right
gang up on me so we've arrived we've
arrived at the point yeah now is the
point at which we should continue we
haven't gotten around a gang up on Zack
yet that is true yeah all right we're in
a bad position of gang up on him given
that the camera's pointed this way yeah
all the controls so yeah he can he can
just shut us down at any moment okay
we're not going to do that no certainly
wouldn't nope nope won't do it okay
um
I think we're there yep next week
same time different place but you come
to the same place and you'll find us
somewhere else or you can go to a
different place but just as long as it's
internet internet
yes Black Box yeah yeah exactly all
right until then be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone